some unemployment claimants are starting
to get their lost wages assistance
benefits
that's the extra three hundred dollar
weekly payments that were dated to go
out
back in august eight news now reporter
joe mohler joining us now live outside
of deter
and joe while the money is good news
there's still some confusion for a lot
of people
yeah a lot of people still have
questions about this because some people
got 300
payments others got 900 and some did not
get any money at all from this
and like you mentioned this is from
august this is back pay from then we
reached out to dieter and the director
got back to us about this
eligibility for the benefits is tied to
those first three weeks of august
if you are eligible for ui or pua the
week of august 1st you will get 300
if you were eligible for that week and
the following two you would get the 900
lump sum many people getting ui have not
received any money that is because
dieter did not want to overwhelm the
system
officials say eligible claimants will
get money over the next few days
today we spoke to patrick flores who is
on unemployment he says every little bit
makes a difference thursday morning
just got a random direct deposit to my
bank account
it was for that extra 300 for us
people here in vegas working the
entertainment industry and
the independent life we really actually
need that
this money is coming from a fema fund
president trump announced additional
money for unemployment
departments nationwide but it was
limited nevada was approved for three
weeks of the three hundred dollars and
then recently approved for an additional
200 million now again if you are a
regular ui
claimant you would not see this money
just yet that money is going to start
coming
out for the next three days so keep an
eye out for that reporting live in las
vegas joe mohler 8 news now